Prrrrr
Ba ba ba bee
Uhh
Prrrrr ba
Bruu bah BAH!!!!
BA bibbity dabada
dababdabda
Babbady bip bo bu
Krrpa ba ba bae
kruu ba bah bah bei
Habada ba PEWDE
BEIDEP-PEP!
pah...wait
why am I not... Am I not live?
Oh.
This is a special message, I suppose
for everybody watching post-this. This is bef-
Oh, no never mind, it's going.
I thought this was going to be a little bit of a secret
Okay
So hi,
Hello everybody, how are you doing?
I'm here. With me, and myself.
By myself.
For a livestream
That you all are watching.
So that's pretty cool right?
I got nothin' else to say.
*catches breath*
I am still 5 minutes early.
There was a whole bunch of kerfuffling going on in the background before this got started
And, eeaauuhhhh...
It was a bit of a scramble to get everything ready, so...
Hello!
Thank you everybody who was here beforehand,
and thank you everybody who is now here
coming in as you're watching this, so
how are you doing, guys?
I can't read chat, it is ...a giant blur.
There's nothing I can do, there's nothing I can see.
It is just a random assortment of people typing as fast as they can,
and it's only gonna get worse as the stream goes on.
So, how are you?
I'm just assuming you're gonna just type outta big-
wall of text
and I'm gonna glean emotions from that as best I can
also, I have water,
because i've been recording all morning
and my throat is a little thrashed so this one is going to be a little more
relaaaaaaaxed
*whispers* and
Calm...
So, hopefully it's good
MMMhhMMM
Also this one is available in glorious
720p
at a whopping 60 frames per second
I don't know if that's gonna work out pretty well
but if it doesn't, you can drop the quality
because
I don't know anything about the technical side of all that junk
So
hope you're all doing wonderful this fine
Thursday?
I don't know what day of the week it is anymore
mmhhmmm
mmhhmm
mhhmmm
oh yes
uh, tell me more
uh, okay
Aloha,
I think I saw
I'm not sure about anything else...
*back in loud* So,
it's kindda the pre-show here so we get to just relax a little bit
and contemplate life
and
Try to decide what we can possibly do with any
I just played a really good horror game by the way...
What was it called...
*Mark try to explore his mind*
l..l.. what is it lit
limbo and vivo..
le la lay and vivo
i can't remember what the name of it, it was very
very
very good name
uh, good
good game
it was a kickstarter
what was it called?
(Lost in Vivo)
Ah, whatever, it doesn't matter
it was made by the same people that did, uh,
Spooky's House of Jumpscares
I'm not gonna play it now, obviously, that video's gonna come out either tomorrow or the next day,
whatever day that may be, but it was really, really, good.
So, I, ah - a lot of people have been asking for more horror stuff,
and it's always a conundrum of -
"No-one's really making any really good horror stuff at this moment in time", (sadly)
so, it's like a waiting game for when there's going to be a good one coming out.
Should I just play a "meh" one?(No)
Should I make a "meh" video?(NO)
Which i dont really want to do anymore, Ugh
And that- yes thats confirming I've made a lot of
(MMMEEEH)
Videos in my life
uhh
but now that Tyler and Catherine are helping me out
Its been
Uhh
Its been really nice
A-although this past weekend i did have family in town so,
Uhh, that occupied a lot of my time but even, even so
I was still able to film with
uh
Rosanna Pansino
and uh
celebrate Matthias's birthday party
and uhh, and then go see Dancing With the Stars with my stepmom
and her friend Ardith, uhh which was a lot of fun
and some of you spotted me in the audience on that broadcast last Monday.
Or this Monday.
The past Monday. The Monday we just had.
Whatever that one was, that's what I'm talking about.
So
Right Now
I am just trying to enjoy life
and uh get these cool videos that we've been working on done.
and there's been a lot of cool stuff.
There's a sequel to Boat Dog coming out.
Uhh, I hinted at it, but not many people picked up on the hint.
Uhh, but there's- there's a, ah shit I even spoiled it.
Ahhh
but that might come out later tonight?
I don't know. I always like doing, late night uh, late night releases with those types of videos.
So, uhh, that's going to happen at some point.
Someone requested a Dab so I'm just going to get my Dab out, of the way.
*crick*
AHHHH! My back!
I Dabbed my back out! Oh ho. I'll never Dab again!
Oh I can't believe it live on YouTube.
Here you saw Markiplier's last Dab. (tragic)
Oh ho ho ho (sarcastic sobbing)
//(Not the Anime OH! HO HO HO! thing) *back of the hand near face*//
What will become of me now that I cannot Dab?
Ok
But anyway, thank you everybody so much for joining us.
I did want to get like music playing in the background
but uhm, uhhh...
I was
*small burp*
busy recording and not able to get that.
So you just get to listen (deeper, sensual voice)
to the lyrical softness of my voice.
(Back to normal audio)
Do the swoop. Is this the swoop?
Is that the swoop?
Is that- is that my swoop?
That's the one I invented.
It's just like the Dab except even stupider.
Ungh
The swoop is going to sweep the nation
It's going to SWOOP the nation.
Everyone's going to be doing the swoop.
I just gotta put a musical number to it.
and then everyone will be swooping their way through school.
Is that not the swoop?
Oh that's not the swoop is it?
Oh I don't think that's the swoop.
Ok, so it's officially 3 o'clock which
I'm- I'm being told by my YOUTUBE OVERLORDS
that I need to actually play a game because this is YouTube gaming prime time.
and they ju-
//gibberish//
... and you guys just don't want to see my face
So I got a lovely game here by the name of
"Clustertruck"
Uhh which a lot of people have been requesting a whole lot of
and it just got fully released just recently.
So it's actually got like music and stuff
and cool bangy-bangy-shooty things.
( *Pew pew*)
and uhh ima play through it.
So
*deep quiet voice*
We'll see what happens
Oh and if anyone's wondering i'm going to be streaming for 2 hours
And then tossing it over to uh the main event in YouTube Prime Time.
So
Clustertruck it is
and no not Undertale. Not right now.
I may- I may- I'm not- Gu-
I'm not lying. I might do Undertale at a future livestream
Just 2 hours is not enough time to do Undertale
and even like 2 hours split over like however many weeks we're going to be doing this
*some mouth noise he makes idk*
That's barely enough time to actually get through all of Undertale
So
Maybe in the future but that would be like a full day event
and I'd need some emotional support to crutch my way
through playing that game.
I'd need to tag team with my buddies just to able to slog through it.
Oh and then constant ridicule of the comments would be unending and horrifying
So
Anyway
So let's get over to
hopefully this is still set up
*game music jamming*
Yeah!
Ok now I don't know if, how the music is going to sound.
So I'm going to do an audio test here
Oooh that didn't work.
Ok
If it goes horribly...
//Which it will//
Oooh no that's not going to work.
Ok good.
I saved your ears from an explosion of sound that you guys didn't want.
So just, generally give me a scream *hand flailing* if the music is too quiet.
and give me a *gooh* like a haunted ghost sound
but he's like, got spina bifida and
he's little nasely because his allergies are too much.
Give me like a- a sick ghost.
You know what I mean?
So, if it's too quiet.
So sick ghost if it's too quiet,
Screaming in agony if it's too loud.
//Spina Bifida is a birth defect when a baby's spinal cord develops improperly. The more you know~//
Huh, it's just as I suspected.
I can't glean any data from, haha, the crap that you're saying down there.
But I- I- think the general consensus is that it's a little too loud.
Is that it?
Yeah. I think...
Yeah. I think- I think...
I thi- I think
Yeah, a little...
Ok. How about that?
Ok, is- is that better?
Is that better?
Ima listen, Ima listen to the live- livestream here
Wait hang on.
Get ready.
[Past Mark]
Ok how about that?
[Present Mark]
Wait.
[Past Mark]
Is- Is that better? Is that better?
Ima listen, Ima listen to the live- livestream here
[Past Mark]
Wait hang on.
Get ready.
//Present Mark now//
Oh now it's too quiet.
Oh, ok I got it. Ok I- I got it
It was fine before. It was fine before. IT was FINE before. It was FIINE. It was fine.
Everybody was causing a kerfuffle.
They got the instructions all messed up.
And now, and now they don't KNOW.
Now they don't know. Ok.
So. This should be ok.
It-
*Mark noises*
Ok
Probably
Probably ok?
Too quiet?
*Loudly*
Man I don't know when you're talking about what you're talking about
For all I know the menu music is more muted than the other music
I don't know what these crap are
It's good. Ehh whatever.
We're just going to roll with it.
If- If- I'll- Uhh someone will tell me if it's bad
Alright so I- I've never played the full game before.
I did one video on it and it was when I was very tired
And most of my commentary was just...
(orgasm followed by stroke)
So I wanted to try to do something a little more intelligible
But you know that's not going to happen so I don't even know why i'm bothering with talking about it
So, World one, like Mario. In the dessert.
*Loud ingame music*
See, I told you it was going to be louder when you got in there.
Oh, I t- I told you guys
I told you guys it was going to be louder once we got in there.
Oooh, ok
Uhhhn
Yeah yeah I know
I know it's just the first level.
Weeee
*bones cracking*
Oh hohohohoho
I thought I had that
I thought I was through the gateway
Oh I'm dumb
Oh I'm very dumb
Oof
Ok
My problem, oh, my problem is that I'm trying to sprint
when I shouldn't be spranting (ok)
Nyurh
There we go
Nyurh!
There we go.
See it's been a while so i'm not
umm there we go that should've been a lot more smooth
and hopefully you guys won't hold that against me and constantly ridicule me.
Never endingly in the comments down below.
because as you all know...
Oh man, I did terribly
and I have no friends
Ok
So, so you know...
So you know for a f-aahh-ct
You know for a fact that this isn't going to go perfectly
But I do enjoy the fact that there is music now in the game
Which did not exist before
Oh boy
And- a- a-  I believe that I played through some of these
levels like, as they were going along.
So
We're going to be...
We're going to be taking our time with this and
meticulously going through
I mean, i've got you've got...
Woahhh I've
*frank?*
I didn't know where I went there
So
Ehh
So we're going to be taking our t- uhhh
So we're going to be taking our time through this
because you've got me locked and ready
for a full 2 hours.
Not that we're going to do full 2 hours of this
mind you
we're going to do uhh
we're going to do another game
uhh we're going to do Clustertruck for 1 hour
and then we're going to do another game
that's actually very, very, VERY close to my heart
It's one of my favorite games of all time
And i'm super duper excited to able to tell you guys about it
because, or show it to you because it- it taps into every
little bit of what I love about games
and and like my history in gaming
and I haven't had a chance to play it
on my own yet because
I don't have any time to play video games on my own anyway
So what am I going to be doing with my life
Other than tryin' to speed through this
And uh
Do what I need to do
But it is such a good game
It's such a good game ( fails while reminiscing)
And uh it was recently remastered
If that's a clue for you
But, oh, it going to be good
Oh its going to be good
And then maybe some bonus towards the end
But as I have discovered in livestreaming
Two hours is not a lot of time
So
But
Settle down
Relax
Grab some snacks
This is the less frantic day
Gyuuh- guh guh
Jesus
Well it's going to be
A lot more frantic once I start
Screaming at myself at how bad I am
At Clustertruck
Is it because I haven't had enough practice?
Ok
Oh
Oh that's what that's been
They're all turning over on the left side there
Okay
So I know you guys are al- already watching
Hundreds of
Pro
Clustertruckers out there
But i'll get up to that level soon
You'll see
This is actually something that I enjoy very much so
And hopefully, you guys will too
*Sound of vehicle ignition*
What was that?
Take off my shirt?
I don't think that would be appropiate for anything
I!
Okay
I mean
I did have to put a pause in the workouts I've been do-
I've been- I've been working out a lot
Like i'm, i'm not bragging
I'm not saying "Hooh i've been working out a lot"
But I literally have been, Uh, taking personal training
Just to try and take better care of myself
And man!
Not only- uh, I mean it's fine
I'm ok with the work
Like I used to do a lot of work
And now that Tyler's back
Like he's a very physically active guy
So he encourages me to get out more
And we rock climbing more
And we're doing a bunch of stuff
And uh, we're, trying to uh, trying to film some of these
Random crap things that
We're going to be doing in the future
Games are fun
Mark looks sarcastic. Oh no...
why are you still here
why am i still here
why are any of us here
do we really exist
what is existance
what is the meaning of existance
what is life
i mean i could be doing other things
look
i dont even know what im doing anymore
im not even listening to the video now
im still bored
wanna play a game
no?
rude.
im annoying you?
fine then ill just be quiet
no more talking
starting now
i cant do this anymore
so
what do you wanna talk about
what did you say?
did you just ask me to go and find my core message?
go do it now?
is it because im not vegan?
please keep me from writing captions
yeah im leaving
just kidding im still here
youre halfway there
wHOAAOOAAOOO
LIVING ON A PRAYERRRRRRRRRR
Don't move
Don't move Don't move
Don't mo -- *Grunts*
Fuck you. God dammit.
*honk*
Why now?
Why you -- Stay. Stay. Stay. Stay.
GOOD!
*quite angrily* STAY
*sigh of relief*
Uh.
It's easy to the end
It's easy to the end!
*Random Grunts and noises* (His sanity is slowly slipping away)
OH..Now it's actually antagonistic!
Now it's actually being a son of a bitch!
Now it's legitimately hating me..
Now it's being-
I am 100% triggered right now..
Oh. There's no truck there! I did it into the ground!
I was fine every other time when I wasn't using my ninja cable!
No!
Agh I wish I had double jump.. I wish upon a star!
*Teeth clenched* I don't get why you can't have both!
Oh No!
Ah, my caaable was on coool down!
It's doing it intentionally!  *Cries*
It's intentionally targeting him
Ohh, Fuck off you're making it impossible!
*Sighs* It's literally making it impossible.
Oh, It's so much bullshit!
Okay, Yes.. Keep doing it way up there! Way up there!
Good, good, good, good
Yes, good. Way up there
Oh ho ho, good, good, good
Good... It doesn't know what the hell it's doing..
Oh, it's another one! It's a fast-shooty one! I should get out of the way!
*Mark Cursing under his breath*
Oh, That's not good
Well, That's...Okay..
*Mumbles*
Right
Wha- Why did I die?
If I get hit by a rocket do I die?
Well, you shouldn't have so many rockets.. That's not fair!
That's the opposite of fair!
How am I supposed to be able to do this?!
Oh god, there's so many of them!
Oh jeez.. Okay!
We made it so far.. Now where are you going to take me now?
Ahhhhhh, Shit!
*Sound of Mark dying inside*
FUCK YOUUUUUU
Fuck you!
I hate that! Why is that a feature?
Why is- AGH!
It blew up the one I was going for!
Why is it a feature to randomly move me?!
Why is that a feature?
I mean it must be part of the game otherwise it's just a bug!
I hate to think there was a bug!
I'd like to blame that the developers are just idiots! And don't know how to program correctly!
So they got a random jitter feature
And they were like..*Mocking tone* Meh that's probably good, It's game play!
*Angry Attempts*
*Grunting*
*Annoyed tone of voice*  Go..
Where are we going? x2
That's not good!
That's not good...
Uh! Oh, go very slowly!
Very slowly!
*Mark's soul trying to escape him or yawing*
How many worlds are there? x2.. I need to know. Am I almost done?
Am I almost done?
Am I almost done with this?
Am I almost done with this terrible, stupid, pretty good game?
It's not terrible, and the developers aren't idiots
I'm just mad X[
*Is- Is that happiness?!*
No..
I was- I grappled the very back of that truck
Why? Why? Why? Why? Why? Why? Why? Why? Why? Why?
*Sigh* go...
Oh no's, grunts, and random words.
*Mark having a literal seizure*
*Moment of clarity*
mark.exe has stopped working
DETERMINATION (Get it? XD)
(What is that face?)
(Don't give up Markimoo!)
*Smug face* (YOU DID IT!)
(Mark are you okay? Talk to us!)
Ugh
Yeah of course they hid the goal..
Cause that's uhh, that's something you can tell on the first try, definitely
Most definitely
Weeee
*snarls in frustration* grrr
I'm okay
I'm okay (*r u sure?*)
I'm okay.
I just need to ride one of these bad boys down
No that's- No that's- That's no- That's
Okay whatever
You know what? Oww
Ohhh ow
Nooo
*dying inside* GIMME!
GIMME SOMETHING TO GRAB ON GIMME SOMETHING TO GRAB ON GIMME SOMETHING TO GRAB ON GIMME SOMETHING TO GRAB ON!!!!!
grrrr
*sits in silence*
*still silence*
*just 14 minutes to go :)*
*wait for it...*
*thunk*
*exasperated* whaaatttt??
*wimpers*
*sigh*
I just want consistency, that's all I want.
I want consistency, predictability, reliability, something I can know and feel and love and
why did I go so high there?
I don't get it!
See, it changes, oh man...
nnnnnooOOOOOOOO!!!!!!
Ohhh really??
*you can do it Markimoo!!*
*I can't watch*
oooHHH REALLY??
I SLIDE OFF? I SLIDE OFF??
There's slide mechanics in this too
Oh great.
Great
See the- This doesn't make any goddamn sense
*grimly* do not knock me off
do not
Nestled in your bosom right now
Just don't fucking do it, it's that simple- Oh Jesus
Oooo I'm not gonna make this am I?
grrraaaAAHHHHH!!!
AOOHHHH
MYYYYY
GAWWWDDDD!!!!
*snarls*
*a bit of Mark's soul leaves him*
What- I was still alive there? Oh was I still alive?
Oh, yeah, there I was still alive for some reason
For some reason I was still alive there
even though, you know, when you impact into something, you're supposed to die.
Like I get that, I get the rules here. I- I understand how this works
so, why wouldn't you just do it?
Don't fucking knock me off.
I was trying to jump, it just didn't jump
It didn't- It didn't fucking jump
FRRRR
OWWHHH I EVEN GOT THE TRUCK!
I EVEN NAILED THAT TRUCK!
I FUCKING TOSSED THE TRUCK AND NAILED IT
and it still didn't FUCKING work!
This level sucks (*yeah, we know :( *)
A little plain and simple suck
See why in that jump after that do you go super high?
Even, I wasn't going fast. I wasn't on the back of it or anything.
You just- You just do. You just go high
Like how does that make any sorta sense?
Doesn't make any semblance of sense
OH FUCK off with you!
Fuck off, I'm not going to be able to get it.
Oh maybe- maybe- Oh maybe...
NOOOO!!!!! (*rip caption editors*)
*orgasmic sounds*
oh fuck
Oh, I'm not okay!
I'm not okay
What else we got?
Freezes all trucks
Backs truck to the latest trucky truck truck- What?! (*lmao*)
Fuck's that mean?
Supertruck
I don't know
'Makes game super epic. All points are doubled while in epic mode'
I'd like that
Sure
whatever
*exhale*
Okay
I'm okay
(inaudible)
I don't know what this ability does
(*sure you do, it backs truck to the latest trucky truck*)
I don't wanna know
frankly
gruhhaaa!
Why- why- why- w- w- why- I would've had that.
I freaked out
I would'a had that. I would'a had that first try.
That was super easy. Why the fuck did I freak out?
Maybe cause I'm super on edge and like my blood pressure is about 325.
I need some sweet black tar heroin to calm my nerves.
Ugh
Someone get some... literal...
What's the wor- What's that Russian drug, the one they inject between their toes cause it melts your skin?
That one!
That's what I need.
Ugh
Krukinfrumin- Kru- Krickfrumin- Kricfrumin [and more attempts at the word]
(I think he means 'krokodil' aka 'crocodile')
It was too soon. It was- It was too soon.
Ok ohhh
Thank you
W- Oww my face
*inhale and exhale*
I love... backtruck. What the fuck
Don't know what that did.
What the fuck?
I don't fuck- [inaudible]
Uh oh
Shit fuck
*inhale and exhale* happy happy happy happy
*laughs* I was just about- I was literally just about to be like "Ok, I'm over it, I feel better,"
and then instantaneously-
I fail ohh man
I wanna- I wanna- I wanna punch.
I wanna punch
mmmI wanna punch
mmmmI want to punch
I wanna punch
Punching's nice
Punching's good
Happy... happy happy happy happy
There's no way
Oh this is a mistake
Well that didn't do shit!
Oh sheezus
Oh
Okay
That worked
Kind of
Egh, okay
Alright, uh oh, good thing, good
Good, ya- you definitely avoided it heh
No NO GRAB ONN ... YOU FLAMING FUCK!
UGHHHHH IT BUMPED ME!!
WHY?!!
WHY DOES IT BUMP ME?
IF ANYTHING I WAS PRESSING IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION!!
Oh Jesus
Oh no, oh no
NO NO
Goddamnit!
This is like luck, cause I'm on the lead truck